las esperanzas de llegar a un acuerdo
comercial del break city se
desvanecieron otra vez pero las
conversaciones están listas para
continuar ni la unión europea ni reino
unido están dispuestos a tirar la toalla
todavía
huevos zinc ambos creemos que es
responsable a este punto dar la milla
extrajo en consecuencia ordenamos a
nuestros negociadores continuar con las
conversaciones para ver si es posible
alcanzar un acuerdo incluso en esta
etapa tardía handy which iván a veces
ladies stage los libros consideraron la
fecha límite de este domingo como el
último esfuerzo para alcanzar un acuerdo
pero las diferencias en las partes
centrales del pacto hicieron que la
negociación continúa el primer ministro
boris johnson dice que él está más que
listo si reino unido deja el mercado
común europeo el 31 de diciembre sin un
acuerdo
donde hay vida y esperanza continuaremos
las conversaciones para ver qué podemos
hacer
brindé mi libro entretanto prepárense
con confianza para el primero de enero
para comerciar con los términos de la
organización mundial del comercio si es
necesario viaje una sensación de
optimismo podría perdurar en bruselas
pero en las calles de londres parece que
la esperanza de la gente se está
agotando
el acuerdo no traerá beneficios para mí
ya perdí mi derecho a viajar perdí
literalmente no hay ningún beneficio con
una buena suerte o creo que ha habido
tanta incertidumbre sobre el futuro con
la pandemia y en general la ansiedad que
la gente tiene sobre el mundo y lograr
un acuerdo definitivamente sería algo
bueno reino unido está camino a dejar la
unión europea por completo en tres
semanas con acuerdo o sin él la falta de
un pacto con su mayor socio comercial
podría interrumpir la llegada de barcos
con comida también podría poner en
peligro la manufactura británica y
disparar las confrontaciones entre las
embarcaciones de reino unido- y las
extranjeras que pesquen en aguas
británicas